hello grammarians we're going to start
talking about pronouns today
and of course that begins with the
question what are
pronouns
allow me to answer that question by way
of a demonstration
emma laughed so hard milk came out of
emma's nose
zach lifted the log
zach found a worm under the log
so these sentences don't have pronouns
but what they do have is repeated nouns
you know we have emma and then we say
emmas again and then we say zack and the
log and then we say zach and the log
but people are smart right we have
relatively long attention spans and so
if we start off a sentence talking about
emma
and we're pretty sure that we're still
talking about emma we don't need to say
that name twice we don't need to say
emma and then emma again
so what a pronoun does is it allows you
to
take out the unnecessary noun
when we already when we're very certain
we know what we're talking about so you
don't have to say emma a million times
you can replace emma with her
same thing applies to the second two
sentences we don't have to keep on
mentioning zach and the log when we know
what we're talking about so the first
sentence would still read zach lifted
the log but then in the second sentence
we can replace the name zach since we
already know who we're talking about
with the word he and we can replace this
little phrase the log with it since we
know we're talking about the log
now words like her and he and it are all
pronouns
so what are pronouns they are words that
stand in for other words
now obviously her he and it are not the
only pronouns in english but for now i
just want you to think about the idea
that a pronoun is a word that stands in
for another word
you can learn anything
david out